okay so this is fascinating I kind of
stumbled on this the other day and I
wanted to kind of connect the dots for
you I started looking at all these
things in there's like a common
denominator excess calcium
now when I say excess calcium I'm
talking about calcium that's locked up
in the body it's not necessarily just
because you have too much calcium let's
just say it's unavailable calcium it's
like plugging everything up because it's
unavailable it's not ionized it's not
broken down and there's too much of it
so it's called hypercalcemia in the
blood and the calcium is going in inside
the cell inside the cell and outside the
cell you have 10,000 times the
concentration of calcium outside the
cell so when that calcium starts going
inside the cell intracellular calcium
that's what I'm also talking about that
too okay so when I talk about excess
calcium and talking about calcium in the
wrong place of your body alright we're
not talking about excess calcium in the
bone all right so check this out this is
incredible let's just kind of go through
what calcium can do hey that rhymed okay
so let's just start right up here in
China chest pain calcium causes
stimulates the sympathetic nervous
system that causes contraction of the
smooth muscle the cardiac muscle and the
nerve the nerve muscle then nerve
nothing there muscle but the neurology
so too much calcium can cause a cramp of
the heart and cause angina
it's chest pain and even a heart attack
because the heart is contracting too
much and it's not relaxing because they
don't have enough magnesium okay now
arrhythmias too much calcium but just so
you know low calcium could also cause
arrhythmias too but more likely it's
excess calcium because it affects the
electrical conductivity of the heart so
you have atrial fib
too much calcium and the heart rate too
high too much calcium you can even have
a stroke because it excess calcium will
stimulate too much fibrin and that goes
in there and it starts plugging stuff up
because remember calcium is kind of like
the cement that patches stuff up in the
body and if there's damage in the
arteries for example it goes in there
cause blacking and a thorough squatter
clacking and it plugs up the arteries so
it's trying to help you but it's
basically plugging everything up and
then this alone will cause a heart
attack all right high blood pressure why
because the the arteries are not elastic
anymore and you're going to get like an
adrenal problem would be excess cortisol
will cause a high systolic blood
pressure first so the excess calcium
okay now fibroids I did a whole video on
this and I talked about calcium
deficiency what I should have done is
clarified it means unavailable calcium
because it's locked up in the cells and
it's unavailable so it would be
deficient but five calcium controls the
communication of cells and if that
calcium loses control then the cells
plural rate and they they start
duplicating and start growing and you
start getting tumors and fibroids and
polyps and pimples and cancer and from
the loss of control of calcium okay
calcium stimulates the sympathetic
nervous system and that therefore it
messes up the parasympathetic so you can
have a bladder valve problem because of
the autonomic nervous system
now you can't relax and contract that
bladder muscle so you're going to fluid
retention yet it's not going to come out
all the valves are controlled with the
autonomic nervous system so if calcium
causes too much it's going to create it
in balance with your autonomic nervous
system you're going to Pete way too much
at night and you're going to have a
valve problem and then we got cramps one
cause of
cramps is too much calcium we talked
about at that another video and then
you're going to get something called
soft tissue calcification and soft
tissue calcification that's in the
arteries as plaque the joints is
spurring and grinding and popping and
clicking and stiffness and all the itís
like bursitis tendinitis arthritis all
the addresses because there's calcium
deposits that are going all over the
place
stenosis that's the the canal on the
spinal column is getting smaller because
there's a buildup of calcium around the
canal and then tetany which is twitching
underneath the left eyelid cataracts
that's calcium in the eyes joint
clicking all excessive calcium itching
and hives is excess calcium constipation
is excess calcium why because what's the
common remedy people use magnesium the
constipation because it lowers the
calcium and relaxes the colon but you
can be very fatigued if you have excess
calcium decrease reflexes week so we
have the smooth muscle you lose tone
with with too much calcium and that's
another thing with the colon it's all
smooth muscle so that actually just kind
of gets all flabby in congested because
of excess calcium so you get a hypo
smooth muscle contraction and and what
smooth muscle you have the bronchial
tubes you have the arteries in the heart
you have the cut of the colon all that
is effective effected and then we have
insomnia too much calcium so be your
like your head can't go to sleep with
your body's tired anxiety depression
thirty percent of time it's from
hypercalcemia so that's all we want to
give the person more magnesium for that
bronchial constriction boom excess
calcium asthma why because calcium when
it ionizing
goes into the tissues it helps the
mucous membranes it protects you against
a lot of different things but if it's
not if it's clogging everything up you
get asthma you'll get the chronic cough
at night so you had this chronic cough
and then mucous membranes are all
swollen of the colon of the sinus and
the lung so we get a lot of mucous
membrane's problem - colon and viruses
come out of remission when you get
excess calcium - canker sore
yeah that's excess calcium so here's
some facts the calcium stimulates
sympathetics causes contraction of
smooth muscle calcium channel blockers
are used for the heart for high blood
pressure why don't they just get to the
root of it they never do that magnesium
is the natural calcium channel blocker
because it opposes calcium high
sympathetic dominant causes low
parasympathetic alright let's talk about
the causes I'm not just saying stop
consuming calcium unless it's calcium
carbonate and the person is taking on a
calcium but many times the root cause of
excess calcium is a lack of fat soluble
vitamins because people are avoiding fat
they think it's bad but fat cybo
vitamins are needed to transport the
calcium like vitamin F is all the
essential fatty acids in fish oil and
these essential fatty acids are
converted to an available type of
essential fatty acids called conjugated
linoleic acid CLA with some microbes in
your gut so there could be a digestive
problem
that's now allowing you to utilize this
fat so low vitamin F that's essential
fatty acids and fish oils low vitamin k2
we did a video on that even low vitamin
D can cause that but I'm going to
explain this because high vitamin D will
cause hypercalcemia as well so let me
kind of clarify what I mean by that if
the person has low vitamin D the para
thyroid gland will overreact
it will overreact the parathyroid gland
will overreact and spike the vitamin D
storage in that gland and then that's
what causes the hyper calcium state so
there's a whole chain of reactions so
with this situation you can have too
much or too little vitamin D depending
on what's going on the other thing too
is let's say you don't have enough bile
and your gall bladder you're not going
to absorb any of these fats so it
doesn't even matter so you want to kind
of keep going deeper and deeper deeper
you find the root problem but I put a
lot of people on omega-3 fatty acids of
fish oils k2 vitamin D for excess
calcium and it's a great remedy for all
these things right here okay now we also
have cortisol stress can cause this as
well because it makes the body alkaline
calcium can't travel an alkaline body
okay so we have to certify and that's
why apple cider vinegar ionizes calcium
for cramps and it gets rid of cramps
because it mobilizes calcium and it's
good for a lot of different things
alright low hydrochloric acid in the
stomach could also be the source of
excess calcium and so that's kind of a
summary of what's going on but the heart
is really really it really needs a lot
of this fat because it runs on oxidized
fatty acids that not on glucose it runs
on fat alright so I hope this helped and
it might be a little complex so you
might have to watch this multiple times